è una cosa molto importante il nostro
scherzando è molto importante allora io
una cosa la roma è eravamo a roma per il
romics ok
eravamo distanza insieme io e te che i
sì sì sì era un istanza io te c'era
qualcun altro mi di cosa si procede
anche tu per il ricordo di questa cosa
va vera di jesolo serio saranno del
cornetto ciccio grave comunque
che c'entra nuova aveva infatti
l'occasionale line temporalmente avevamo
sto bagni in comune e io avevo lo
spazzolino uguale hai capito uguale al
tuo dentista era valido e io non avevo
mai se è ma perché è il segreto del
cazzo che isolava diventi contrastate da
lì è partito tutto fare dice io vi sono
agenti contestazioni e la via abbiamo
condiviso la stessa sacra spazzino male
tantissima stima di megas disegna no
aspetta la casaccia e di segnare devi
farlo chi siamo
come si può scegliere una parola si dice
una parola pro veloce che sia facile
come siete facile giorgio lo zero ciccio
gamer no non è facile nel carosello e
uomo tante quelle gambe ciao piene il
treppiede 6 segnare ma pace che il
popolo ma delle persone note di pietra
era veramente quello era veramente
quello che sto million inglese questo
milan inglese
i nomi in inglese ok ma nei fatti non ci
riconosce sono tutti dei dei peni
gigante ma basta fare il pisello bengasi
fermarti un pelo prima ci facevano
schifo ma chi governerà un tic man
deciderà il tuo sasha e chi lo conosce
ma anche messo inglese no per apple sia
un file qual video stickman tratteggiata
e 3 no dovete soffermarmi su questo ci
siamo capiti il browser è in realtà una
cazzata l'accesso ad uno si può dire un
altro modo cioè questo caldo ma etico di
cos'è che la roba là sopra che arriva
cos'è cos'è questa è una palla e la fa
questa fase capo altro veramente bene
recato a questa palla antico cosa questo
che cazzo di giuseppe ha spiegato
aspetta non ho capito sta cosa c'è
scritto disclose molti l'inizio andato
vicino che st 3
cosa stai facendo
mi sono proprio lui ho intuito subito
campo da cole orto ballo times sun
scrive non solo sta facendo ma sta
facendo check in anche perché era era
era molto più semplice del previsto dal
verbo è l'america ma fan cuore abbiamo
ragazzi aspettino non c'era una macchina
era veramente difficile quello che so
ricerca di ti amo
no non è di non è difficile ve la faccio
e velocissimo ma che casa d'altri
tra l'altro non è per niente quello dei
premi si fa una chitarra giusta qualcuno
mi sono fosse un battere
raga non urlate se lascari 105 mitch è
uno dei pochi che potrei dominarlo
el'ala
ma perché poi tutto nel cast ad ormea a
quanti si trova un bellissimo bellissimo
ma hai fatto troppo bene ho capito
adesso il gioco gioco la grafica è
quella sì l'hanno fatto probabilmente
tramite scritto il punto di un libro
sono proprio lui come the phantom le due
cose
lorenzo la mia questo ciò che restava
tutte le parol so niente di queste cose
allora questo è un po strano perché non
so cosa voglia dire però e lo faccio lo
stesso colpa è di segnare una cosa che
non sa cosa voglia dire qualcuno ma mai
troppo disco sembra un altro una
pagnotta sentiamo arrivare a dire quindi
ho messo una parola f plan ai cipolla la
decima hai capito lo svago ma non
esistano si fa ma che cos'è cos'è il
flauto di pan e non lo so quello di vito
rago un po le panne scusa cosa facevo
sempre con te cos'è che scritte
scrive ha sbagliato perchè l'ha fatto sì
che la prima volta che un secondo ai
mobile sopracciglio allora che doveva
vincere al malefico sia facilissimo
prima ho detto pan
cos'è questa violino come ci divertiamo
padella a walk lo sta arrivando sta
arrivando
[Applauso]
ma arrivato normalmente subire meno
perché la vince su rig
questo si chiama cassetta postale
casella lettere che vaga allora una
casella è una cassetta e lo scrive
gianni poggi allegata e marina zancan
faccia io farei una petizione per
rinominare la appoggia lettera e
mannaggia al casa l'ultimo verdetto sul
primo l'ultima era allora 4 l'intera
gamma allora no
[Musica]
una donna più grande mercato prima di
voi è capace quello dove non è tipo da
lui lo re noiosa parte chi è sul ma è
l'abilità di futura
no penso di 70 punti a maria che
vogliono più vedere ai ragazzi questo
era scrivo io faremo un altro episodio
perché nel caso non si fosse capito ci
siamo divertiti il canale dei ragazzi
trovate in descrizione nel caso non li
conoscesse ma la vedo difficile ma certo
come trova sotto ragazzi iscrivetevi al
canale e noi come sempre ci vediamo aru
proseguito dei ragazzi
[Musica]